d'istres la parole est un monsieur
damien abad pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci beaucoup
madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
finances et des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre ce n'est pas en
réduisant drastiquement les dotations de
l'état envers les collectivités
territoriales que vous allez inverser la
courbe du chômage
bien au contraire et le rapport récent
de la cour des comptes de ce jour le
rappelle - 11 milliards d'euros de
dotations de l'état en faveur des
collectivités territoriales ça veut dire
moins un investissement moins
d'investissements sur les collectivités
qui investissent près de 70% de
l'investissement public
ça veut dire moins de croissance et ça
veut dire moins d'emplois notamment dans
le secteur du btp 66 à 80 mille emplois
en moins à trois ans voilà le résultat
de ces baisses des dotations et voilà le
résultat de les responsabilités de votre
politique
alors face à cela monsieur sapin vous
nous répondez
il faut diminuer les frais de
fonctionnement vous nous répondez il
faudrait réduire le personnel
mais quelle cohérence entre cette
affirmation est ce que vous faites ici à
paris en augmentant de 60 mille postes
de fonctionnaires
quelle cohérence monsieur sapin entre ce
que vous dites dans la presse sur les
collectivités locales
est ce que vous faites en refusant notre
de notre politique de lutte contre la
fraude sociale et en refusant notre
politique de maîtrise des dépenses
sociales et quelques errances monsieur
sapin en vantant les mérites de la
décentralisation et de l'autre côté en
faisant souffrir toujours plus nos
territoires nous nous retrouverons
demain avec dominique bussereau avec
françois baroin avec tous les élus
locaux et tous les présidents de
départements de france pour dénoncer
cette gabegie territoriales pour des
zones et cette injustice de la loi note
qui est tout sauf la nôtre monsieur le
bénisse et nous vous attendons nous
attendons de vous des explications nous
attendons de vous des choix et nous
attendons de vous surtout des réponses
concrètes
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple quand enfin allez vous
arrêter de mettre au pilori les
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur haddad l'appareil est un
monsieur khadir l'état chargé du budget
monsieur écarte merci madame la
présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député nous n'avons pas la même
lecture du rapport de la cour des
comptes qui a été diffusée ce matin
parce que finalement la cour des comptes
qu'est ce qu'elle constate elle fait les
mêmes constats que le gouvernement que
les dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités locales sur les trois ou
quatre dernières années ont augmenté de
façon substantielle en tout cas bien
plus que les dépenses de l'état
3 à 4% d'augmentation régulière des
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
call
c'est le constat que fait la cour des
comptes et elle invite ses collectivités
territoriales à économiser sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement parce que il
est facile de regarder toujours son
nombril mais quand on stigmatise la
dépense publique comme c'est
régulièrement fait sur ces bancs la
dépense publique mesdames messieurs les
députés
ce n'est pas seulement le budget de
l'état ce sont les budgets sociaux mais
ce sont aussi et au moins pour une part
équivalente
les dépenses des collectivités
territoriales nul ne veut ici
stigmatiser des collectivités qu'ils
s'administrent librement dans le cadre
fixé par la loi
mais s'il est un peu facile de déportés
l'endettement sur l'état en disant il
n'y a que l'état qui doit verser des
dotations aux collectivités qui l
équilibre leur budget et ensuite montré
du doigt le déficit du budget de l'état
alors le dialogue se poursuit le premier
ministre a annoncé à fond
d'investissement pour engager un
milliard d'euros d'investissements pour
les collectivités le fonds de
compensation de la tva que vous
connaissez bien prendre en compte les
dépenses d'entretien des bâtiments mais
il n'est pas question de revenir sur
cette trajectoire qui permet de revenir
à un déficit public tout compte
consolidé diminuer merci monsieur le
ministre à part est à monsieur olivier
falorni